c'est en 2002 que naît l'idée de créer
le centre de recherche de l'inria saclay
et surtout de l'agrandir l'idée est
enfin devenu une réalité après deux ans
de travaux le bâtiment alan turing s'est
agrandie et fait maintenant douze mille
mètres carrés il ya plusieurs équipes
qui étaient logés ailleurs qui sont
maintenant dans ce bâtiment on en a
aussi des plateformes de recherche et
d'expérimentation qui sont installés une
plateforme de capteurs sans fil par
exemple fit qui installés ici d'autres
plateformes des ressources de calcul
supplémentaire qui sont dans une salle
machine
et puis un amphithéâtre tout neuf pour
recevoir des conférences des colloques
des réunions etc
cette extension permettra d'accueillir
douze équipes du centre inria ainsi que
huit équipes du laboratoire informatique
de polytechnique l'école polytechnique
qui est partenaire de ce projet comme
l'université paris sud
le but est de créer une émulation entre
des chercheurs la base de ce que nous
faisons c'est de l'excellence
scientifique car il faut qu'on soit
parmi les meilleurs au monde mais chez
inria nous essayons de faire en sorte
que cette excellence scientifique elle
est un impact c'est à dire elle est un
impact ou bien vers le monde industriel
ou bien vers le monde de la société
parce qu'encore une fois les
technologies que nous développons elles
ont des applications dans à peu près
tous les secteurs de l'économie mais
l'on cite d'applications dans le domaine
de la santé dans le domaine de
l'environnement dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité
autant de préoccupations qui sont plus
de crue préoccupations sociales que des
préoccupations industriel avec ce
nouveau bâtiment l'inria souhaite
continuer à compléter ses équipes avec
des mécaniciens et des chercheurs en
sciences